[Music]
on this Monday night without power for
more than 10 days
frustration festers in parts of Atlantic
Canada for a lot of people it's it's
pretty tough thousands still in the dark
and cold after Fiona decision Quebec
voters in LaBelle Provence cast their
ballots will anything change demanding
Justice and accountability from police
families of murdered indigenous women
speak out
plus Hook Line and stinker
the Scandal that has an American Fishing
Tournament reeling
global national with Donna Friesen
thanks for joining us we begin in
Atlantic Canada where the storm has long
since passed but people can't believe
how long it's taking to get the power
back on Fiona tore through 10 days ago
and thousands of customers still have no
power as Colder Weather sets in the wait
is even more unbearable especially for
vulnerable members of the community like
the elderly and the homeless Global News
spoke to Volunteers in Charlottetown who
say they're disappointed by the
government response many incidents where
we were their first sort of a of access
to a meal in days and we just need
government to step up and do something
we're seeing just such desperate need
and it's just been absolutely
heartbreaking
that's the situation in parts of Prince
Edward Island where downed trees are
making access for Crews difficult it's
an inconvenience many can easily stomach
for a few hours but more than a week and
Counting it's becoming exhausting and
anxiety-inducing power is still out in
parts of Nova Scotia too many of the 415
000 customers knocked off the grid have
their lights back on but as Callum Smith
reports that doesn't mean much to those
who don't
foreign
people in Truro and Beyond have grown
accustomed to this sound over the past
10 days chopping down trees as the
cleanup continues following hurricane
Fiona's impact on the region Ruby duguay
is waiting on insurance to see when
Crews can remove this tree from her
house it's unbelievable really that it
could a tree that size could fall on
your roof and you're still okay
as the days go on without power
temperatures are dropping hovering
around the freezing Mark overnight I
think for a lot of people it's it's
pretty tough we've we've got a friend
she's 68 and she's depending on her wood
stove right now
fire crews are still busy responding to
calls but they're opening the hall as a
comfort center because of those
temperatures there's people out there
that don't have power or heat in their
homes I mean last night we had frost so
we found it important to have something
set up so someone can come in and get a
warm meal and a warm place to stay if
they needed it the frustration is
growing for those who still aren't
reconnected this past weekend I even
went to my work office just to get
everything charged up like having to
rely on other people just to kind of do
get showers get things charged but many
people facing personal challenges on top
of Fiona's nightmare it's not easy I
have a wife who is
on dialysis so that's difficult she's
87. many are unable to work with a Wi-Fi
or power and relying on others for
information the funny thing is my
husband's in Ontario and he's going
getting a lot of the information first
from global news as well as they're
calling he's calling and checking on the
the power and giving me quick text
updates hoping like many others to get
the lights back on as soon as possible
and get some heat in the house Alan
Smith Global News turo Nova Scotia
in Florida the number of people killed
by Hurricane Ian has now risen to at
least 100 rescue crews are still
searching for others who are missing
power has been restored to 2 million
residents but more than 500 000 people
are still without electricity and clean
drinking water is scarce at least 140
boil water advisories are in place
people have been told to conserve what
little clean water they have Ian
decimated Coastal communities last
Wednesday with 240 kilometer per hour
winds and nearly a four meter high storm
surge U.S President Joe Biden plans to
tour the damage Wednesday after visiting
Puerto Rico today that Caribbean island
was ravaged by Hurricane Fiona two weeks
ago
it is election night in Quebec the polls
closed a short time ago and it didn't
take long for the result to become clear
Mike Armstrong is watching the results
come in Mike it wasn't much of a contest
in the end was it
yeah there wasn't a whole lot of
suspense here in Quebec tonight
sometimes pollsters are off Donna uh
that was not the case tonight
um election desks were calling this one
a caq majority within 10 minutes of the
polls closing Francois goes caq
government is going back to the National
Assembly in fact with an even bigger
majority than it had the last time
around they won 78 seats in the last
election they're looking at 90 to 98
this time around it would appear Lego
didn't have a particularly strong
campaign but he has promoted himself as
the protector of the Quebec identity and
the French language and that appears to
have stuck meantime this has been a very
a rough day for two other parties of the
quebecois and the Liberal Party both had
their worst results in four decades in
the last election they've done even
worse than that tonight so very very
difficult the battle for second place is
actually really interesting four parties
splitting the vote each tied at about 15
percent how the results shake down
depend very much on how concentrated
that support is so the Liberals right
now are very popular still in Montreal
very concentrated so they're leading in
13 ridings at the moment the
conservative party for example with that
same 15 percent is very spread out they
are leading in uh note writings at the
moment so the other interesting thing
about these results right now is the
lack of support for the caq government
here on the island of Montreal the caq
is not leading in any of the 27 ridings
in the province's biggest city Donna all
right still another majority for
Francois lagoa Mike Armstrong in
Montreal tonight thanks Alberta will
have a new premier by the end of the
week the governing United conservative
party will announce who the new leader
is on Thursday seven candidates are
vying to replace Jason Kenney and well
as Mike said you can't always rely on
the polls the presumed front-runner is a
woman whose campaign centered on among
other things the idea of Alberta
sovereignty Heather West reports on
what's coming in Alberta
I ran my campaign as you probably saw on
three main issues but it was one issue
in particular a so-called Alberta
sovereignty act that propelled Danielle
Smith the former opposition leader and
media personality into the Forefront of
the United conservative party's
leadership race it will essentially
Endeavor to do will be to allow Alberta
to opt out of certain federal laws and
regulations that the legislation and the
governing caucus ultimately decides is
not in the best interests of albertans
the idea has been controversial and
polarizing but it resonated with the
ucp's base few insiders doubt Smith will
have any trouble emerging Victorious
Thursday from a pool of candidates that
include several former members of Jason
Kenny's cabinet the Border base is I
think 124 000 and we've already seen 90
000 ballots cast so I think the voter
turnout is really high and that speaks
to a change vote but appealing to the
party membership is very different than
appealing to Alberta's entire voting
public and recent polls have suggested
that a UCP leadership race focused on
sovereignty and covet restrictions may
have alienated the majority of Voters
who are more concerned about things like
affordability and health care it's why
during a virtual press conference on
Monday Smith appeared to be shifting her
message vowing to focus first on federal
carbon tax hikes and Children's Mental
Health making sure that we address those
issues is going to be the number one
priority it's not surprising that
Danielle Smith is going to try to
perform this pivot
I think she might be underestimating the
challenge that's involved in the pivot
it's a dance that proved to be too
tricky for Jason Kenney who will step
down this week several months shy of a
single full term the question now is
whether his successor can help the UCP
hang on to power for another one Heather
York's West Global News Calgary
in Ukraine Russian troops are being
pushed back again Ukrainian troops have
made another Advance on the southern
front breaking through Russian lines and
pushing along the dimipro river
threatening Russian supply routes at the
same time the Kremlin staged more
political theater it held a vote in
Parliament to formalize the illegal
annexation of four Eastern regions about
15 percent of Ukraine the outcome of
that vote was never in doubt the idea
was to create a veneer of legitimacy for
what is a flagrant violation of
international law as Crystal gemancing
Reports the reality is that Russia is
losing more ground in Ukraine every day
in spite of being illegal under
international law lower parliamentary
officials in Russia unanimously approve
the annexation of four Ukrainian regions
another fact all but being ignored by
Russia that it doesn't have total
control of all the areas it now claims
as Russian territory
Ukraine continues to battle for every
inch of its eastern Ridge including the
Donetsk oblast Russia's defense Ministry
acknowledged a Ukrainian tank unit
pushed through the Russian lines in part
of the kerson region an aggressive
counter-offensive has resulted in the
liberation of several cities such as
izum harkiv and just recently Limon a
Papito has been organized today in an
attempt to deny the obvious
that the aggressive and adventurist
regime in Russia is heading to its
imminent defeat
this 75 year old Soviet Army veteran is
one of many who has taken part in public
acts of defiance while under Russian
occupation he eventually left kirsaw
knowing he was an easy target
what I was most afraid of was not the
Orcs but the local collaborators Russia
claiming the four regions as its own
will make it even harder for ukrainians
to flee to safer cities the U.S
ambassador to the U.N called on the
security Council to compel Russia to
withdraw its troops and introduced a
resolution to not acknowledge the recent
Russian land grab they changed nothing
about the status and borders of Ukraine
Russia voted against the resolution
China Gabon India and Brazil all
abstained
Crystal gomancing Global News London
Canada is imposing further sanctions on
the Iranian regime in a statement
foreign affairs minister Melanie Jolie
says the sanctions are in response to
gross human rights violations that have
been committed in Iran including its
systematic persecution of women and in
particular the egregious actions
committed by around so-called morality
police 22-year-old Masa amini died in
police custody last month accused of
improperly wearing her hijab her death
prompted widespread condemnation and
protests around the world the new
sanctions Target 25 senior Iranian
officials and nine government entities
Britain's prime minister backtracks
ahead reversing the controversial plan
that tanked the UK's economy
Britain's new prime minister and the
chancellor have made a complete u-turn
on one of their signature economic
policies but I can be frank I know the
plan put forward only 10 years days ago
has caused a little turbulence I get it
I get it
Chancellor quasi-quartang along with
prime minister Liz truss have been in
charge for less than a month and managed
to plunge the Tory party and the country
into a downslide their economic plan
which included a tax cut for the richest
caused the pound to fall to Historic
lows and damage Britain's economic
standing globally both kept defending
their plans as recently as yesterday
with energy bills skyrocketing a painful
covet aftermath war on our continent a
70-year high tax burden
slowing Global growth rates and
glacially slow infrastructure delivery
we couldn't simply do nothing
the ruling conservatives are gathering
for their annual conference senior
Tories are warning of rebellion within
the ranks and Liz truss's future as
prime minister as anything but certain
King Charles and queen consort Camilla
visited Scotland today in their first
joint public engagement since the Royal
morning period for Queen Elizabeth II
ended
people in dunfermland gathered to
welcome the royal couple who were also
greeted by Scottish first Minister
Nicholas sturgeon the king officially
gave City status to the community which
was the capital of Scotland in the 11th
century it's one of eight cities awarded
the new status as part of the late
Queen's Platinum Jubilee celebrations
in the U.S one of the highest profile
trials is underway to hold accountable
lows involved in the attack on the U.S
Capitol on January 6 2021 five members
of the extremist group The Oath Keepers
including Founders Stuart Rhodes are
charged with seditious conspiracy
accused of trying to stop by whatever
means necessary the lawful transfer of
Presidential Power Federal prosecutors
allege they planned an armed Rebellion
to keep president Donald Trump in power
and had amassed weapons in trained armed
teams leading up to The Siege if
convicted they face up to 20 years
behind bars
police Under Fire coming up families of
murdered and missing indigenous women's
speak out about the Discrimination they
say they've faced
it remains as shameful and distressing
statistic in Canada indigenous women and
lgbtq and two-spirit people are six
times more likely to be victims of
violent crime now family members of
Three murdered indigenous women from BC
are recounting what they say were
inadequate negligent and apathetic
responses by the police to the
disappearances of their loved ones nitu
garcha reports and a warning some of the
details in her story are disturbing she
was very compassionate intelligent as
she remembers the wonderful woman she
was Natasha Harrison is once again
pleading to the public for information
on what happened to her twenty-year-old
daughter Tatiana she says her remains
were found on a yacht enrichment on May
2nd after she spent months desperately
searching for her police didn't confirm
those remains were hers until August I
was searching for my daughter's body
like I'm like I'm screaming to people
like something's happened and it's
getting dismissed
five other women speaking out about the
cases of their lost loved ones including
Chelsea Poorman a 24 year old whose body
laid in a Vancouver Mansion for more
than a year yet her death wasn't
considered suspicious Noel Ellie OSU a
14 year old child whose decomposing
remains went undetected by authorities
for months after she vanished while in
Ministry care and Ramona Wilson a 16
year old who was last seen in Smithers
northern BC in 1994. her case remains
unsolved we have been
trying to find answers in what happened
to her who did this to her who murdered
her no one deserves to be treated as
though their missing loved one was not
important or didn't matter the stories
are all unique but their experiences
with law enforcement are similar and so
is the demographic of each victim all
indigenous women whose cases are fraught
with what their relatives say is
negligence a lack of accountability and
discrimination indigenous women
represent over 40 percent of all
homicides this fight only making out
five percent of all women in the country
the family is now hoping to help expose
the pattern of mismanagement and lack of
coordination between jurisdictions
through their news conference with
Amnesty International and the group
families of sisters in spirit whose
founder waited 20 years for an apology
after her mother was struck and killed
by a police cruiser while crossing the
highway near her home the officer who
struck my mother was investigated by a
member of his family on the night of the
accident and was cleared three months
later in a statement the BCR CMP called
these cases part of an ongoing National
tragedy adding we're learning from our
past mistakes that have left prolonged
feelings of being dismissed sadly I hate
to say it but there's more to come if
things don't change Global News Langley
BC
residential school survivors and their
families looking for help can call the
residential school survivors and family
crisis line the number is 1-800-721-0066
the federal government has given back
control of a 120 hectare plot of land in
Ontario to the Mohawk of the Bay of
Quinte the land is known as the
Cuthbertson tract and was granted to the
Mohawk in 1793 in compensation for their
loyalty to the crown during the American
Revolution in 1837 the land about 200
kilometers east of Toronto was
unlawfully given away in 1995 the Mohawk
filed a claim that federal government
did not secure the surrender of the land
and now after years of wrangling about a
third of it has been returned to the
Mohawk along with a settlement worth
more than 30 million dollars
we had a very difficult time to move the
government away from the idea it was
surrender or extinguishment or
termination of rights
we said it's our land we've never
surrendered it
it is important to note this is a
partial settlement covering roughly a
third of the land unlawfully seized in
the 1830s
bait and switch next the fraud that
sparked Fury at a fishing tournament
we've all heard the stories maybe even
told a couple ourselves about the big
one that got away humans have been
telling Tales of sea monsters and epic
struggles with undersea creatures since
ancient times so maybe it's not all that
surprising what a couple of guys in Ohio
were caught doing at a fishing
competition Mike droulet on the Anglers
who cast a complicated line of Lies
welcome to Lake Erie and Huron Ohio you
won't find many Anglers entering
tournaments for the prizes alone
bragging rates though you be the judge I
don't want to sound arrogant or cocky
but I am confident that we should do
well in this Championship
also because
it's just what we do Jake Runyan and his
partner Chase Kaminsky had reason to be
confident they just won three Lake Erie
walleye tournaments in a row and Team of
the Year recognition appeared to be in
the bag
[Music]
your new leaders tournament director
Jason Fisher thought something smelled
fishy Runyan as it turns out had failed
a polygraph a lie detector after a
tournament last year that cost him over
a hundred thousand dollars U.S so Fisher
took a closer look I squeezed the fish I
squeezed the belly and I immediately
felt things in the belly of this fish
hard objects and all hell broke loose we
got Wings inside the fish weighted metal
balls about 340 grams or at the heft of
a can of pop wrapped inside fish fillets
so they would avoid detection
the language from the other Anglers got
a bit salty do you have anything to say
Jake
I got video I'm just you got anything to
say and no neither of the men accused of
cheating said a thing they just laughed
disqualified and disgraced pariahs in
the Lake Erie fishing scene I'm angry
about it I'm sad about it
um I've known Chase and I've known Jake
and um
no longer speaking they're blocked from
me and that's the saddest part because
Tall Tales are a part of fishing but
there has to be honor amongst Anglers
micro light Global News Toronto
and that is global national for this
Monday I'm Donna Friesen tonight's your
Canada is Dildo Cove in Dildo
Newfoundland and Labrador beautiful
place we'd love to see your Canada
please email it to viewers at
globalnational.com and thanks for
watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow bye-bye
[Music]